welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and knives out was one of the most
intricately crafted films of 2019 a
master class at whodunit storytelling
with endless visual details that make
rewatch is a game of foots in their own
right
people loved it so much they announced a
freaking sequel is in the works now
while we typically analyze the nerdier
stuff here knives out does have Captain
America Tony Stark's daughter Zod Yoda
the kid from it and was made by Star
Wars director so you know it's kind of
like new rockstars pulled a MARTA on a
clue board knives out topped our poll of
requested films for me to breakdown so
let's go back through this film scene by
scene for all the Easter eggs and
details that you might have overlooked
spoiler warnings I haven't seen it yet
let's get started knives out opens on
the home of mystery writer Harlan at
thrombi now his name is possibly an
homage to the popular 80's choose your
own adventure book called who killed
Harlow Dorothy the first image shows
Harlan's dogs rushing out to greet us as
we'll see throughout the film the dogs
reaction are a key clue pointing to the
murderer this Chotu character the dog
this is a reference to the Sherlock
Holmes short story the silver blaze and
which Holmes deduce is that the dog
silence means the culprit was a party
they knew several shots show the mansion
interior which the production designer
based on mystery films like death trap
and sleuth actually noticed that sailor
statue this is a nod to jolly Jack Tarr
in the mystery writers home and sleuth
also notice how the house is covered in
art and window designs featuring the
motif of skeletons and skulls this is an
art style called memento mori
translating to remember you are mortal
some Victorian homes would be decorated
this way as a reminder that death comes
for all people rich or poor and here
they show how the thrombi czar know
better than murder the opening shots
also give us a direct look at the trick
window wall up in the attic it's got an
x marks the spot
of a painting of a child entering
through the frame the housekeeper Fran
is framed with her reflection in
Harlan's mirror
later when ransom has shown sneaking
into this room to meddle with Harlan's
medication he's framed in the same
mirror the same way reflecting how Fran
will later witness ransoms treachery and
be the one murder in this film that
finally gets the villain arrested Fran
finds Harlan dead and she smells a
coffee mug reading my house my trolls my
coffee
arta will later sip from this mug in the
final shot suggesting this house and its
comforts are intended for her and next
we meet Marta Harlan's nurse her sister
watches a mystery show with a familiar
voice
we have the nanny cam this is a vocal
cameo by Joseph gordon-levitt a long
time Ryan Johnson collaborator who
starred in Johnson's breakout mystery
film brick and we see how Marta's phone
screen is broken the small detail that
contrasts Marta with the rest of the
thrombi family were often on their
pristine smartphones and it may have
broken as a result of Harlan's
propensity to overturn their go game
board whenever he loses Marta is greeted
by Harlan's granddaughter mag and
Harlan's daughter Linda and her husband
Richard and Linda mentions Harlan's
funeral the members of the family will
actually tell Marta the same thing I
thought you should have been so despite
their falseness clearly none of them
wanted her there
they also consistently mistake what
country or families from families from
Ecuador families from Paraguay your
family is from Uruguay your Brazilian
nurse yeah notice how they all mentioned
South American countries which are all
probably wrong considering Marta's
undocumented family members were likely
from Mexico or Central American country
so each family member is questioned and
our main detective Benoit Blanc observes
occasionally tapping a piano key
this is his nonverbal cue to Elliott to
get back on track and ask what time they
arrived right did you say that all three
of you showed up around the same time so
you're in the area right you guys
probably arrived around the same time
right you two showed up to the party
around the same time so Blanc is the
Sherlock Holmes Hercule Poirot of this
story Daniel Craig plays them with this
so the drawl inspired by southern
historian Shelby Foote he's the first
established writer from Grand Blanc says
um here the behest of a client notice
that Blanc is flanked by a skeleton
possibly foreshadowing how the mystery
client he's referring to is the villain
they gotta watch out for
we need Walt Harlan's son who runs the
family publishing company his wife Donna
and his alright son Jacob and then
Joanie Widow of Harlan's son Neal and
Meg's mother and we get a sense of the
rivalry between the families here and
the telling of Harlan's birthday when
Richard tells it he and Linda are at
Harlan sides when he blows out the
candles but when Walt tells it
his family is that Harlan size
richard quotes hip-hop musical Hamilton
immigrants we get the job done Hey
mammal tonight the public he's bragging
about having seen Hamilton at its
off-broadway premiere before moving to
Broadway it's actually very similar to
the kind of white elitist virtue
signaling that that dad and get out does
and the opening act and mask his true
racism I would have voted for Obama for
a third term if I could best president
in my lifetime during these interviews
notice the reflection on Linda's glasses
shows the outside windows Johnson's
lighting team actually had to rig up
fake windows to create a glare to block
her lenses from accidentally reflecting
the film's crew also in the library
there's a sprained a picture of Linda
Richard in ransom and an elephant
figurine perhaps is another clue of
ransoms involvement with all this since
he knew to drive behind the elephant
statue when return to the mansion
Harlan confronted Richard about his
affair while climbing a baseball notice
that the camera tilts up to Harlan with
these weird eyes behind him it's as if
the shot is telling us keep your eyes on
the ball because yes the ball is
extremely important and when Harlan cuts
off Jodi's allowance the camera glides
past this statue of apparent spanking
their child just like Harlan is doing to
his daughter-in-law here now the moment
Blanc meets Martin watch him very
closely I've been doing a little pokin
you're hard on a part-time basis as a
registered nurse yes Blanc notices
Marta's feet as she walks outside and
then even looks down again to
double-check what he's doing here is
spotting the blood on her shoe that is
revealed to us later
from this moment onward he's figuring it
all out and throughout the film Blanca
hint this to Marta by quoting Sherlock
Holmes something is afoot with this
whole affair I don't know one believe
you know it too the game is afoot hey
Watson yeah he's literally seen ah but
your butt tells me everything I need to
know and knowing that Marta pukes when
she lies forces her to tell the story
the night of the death she and Harlan
played go why can't I beat you at this
game because I'm not playing to beat you
I'm playing to build a beautiful pattern
mortis skills at go come up later in the
context of her worthiness of Harlan's
estate think about it all of her
kids are playing to beat him at his own
game but Marta like her go strategy is
playing her own game attempting to break
this chain it's also worth noting that
her pattern is made with non-white
pieces interrupting the chain of white
pieces reflecting the whole racial
dynamic of Marta's role and overturning
the white dominance of this estate
Harlan Ayers as regrets that have been
kinda to Linda and ransom
Jesus ransom playing life like a game
without consequence some fun details
here as he mentions ransoms name the
knife goes across his throat a little
clue for how ransoms meddling with all
this led to Harlan's suicide and I'll
get to the second detail at the end of
this video so it's interesting how
knives out is revealing the
circumstances of his death early in the
film at the end of Act one you gave me a
hundred milligrams of the good stuff
excuse me but what is the good stuffs
dosage supposed to be that's not right
now okay
so after the medication bottles tumbled
to the floor Marta thought she mixed him
up and under the assumption of Harlan's
coming death Harlan spared her from her
legal trouble by killing himself and
covering up her involvement ironically
Harlan refers to the morphine as the
good stuff when in reality it actually
is the good correct medication
mislabeled fran speculates that Harlan
didn't kill himself it was this whole
movie surprise with Danica McKellar
deadly by surprise is an actual hallmark
movie with Danica McKellar and Fran's
cousin at the medical examiner yes an
important set up for later back on the
night of Harlan's birthday richard
beckons Marta to their political
discussion as a spandy an example of its
immigration point but then he hands her
his cake plate Marta is Harlan's nurse
not the housemaid but uses her as the
help the same way he's objectifying her
to make his stupid point Fran's stash
box and the clock also comes back later
notice it's decorated with cherubs
ashiness Blanca mentions to Marta
gravity's rainbow a 1973 novel by Thomas
Pynchon many considered to be unreadable
blog says he never read the book but he
likes his title which he compares to the
arc of a murder mystery back home
Marta's mother watches an episode of
Murder She Wrote dubbed in Spanish
reflecting how this whole movie is kind
of a classic whodunit retold through
immigrant eyes the groundskeepers play
by M and
Walsh but originally the part was going
to be played by magician and actor Ricky
J but he passed away before filming may
include a photo of him in the
groundskeepers shed Marta covers her
track he's in the magnet to scramble the
tape walking back over her muddy
footprints tossing a broken trellis
piece but then later when the dog
fetches it back for block the shot
frames Marta beside this circular hole
hinting that Marta is the donut hole
that the Blanc has been seeking next
arrives America's [ __ ] Chris Evans as
Hugh ransom Drysdale Harlan's grandson
and our villain the movie doesn't really
hide this we get plenty of clues the
barking dogs saying only to help call
some Hugh but also yeah he's just a smug
prick who clearly knows something [ __ ]
[ __ ] a lawyer is played by Frank Oz the
voice and puppeteer of Yoda who had just
worked with Rian Johnson in the last
Jedi
Blanca discovers the trick window and
dried mud on the window sill but when
you think about it when Marta went
through that window her muddy shoe did
not touch the edge which tells us that
someone else must have gone through this
window
of course we find out later it was
ransom whose foot if you look closely
does scrape that sill to leave the mud
during the will reading ransom can be
seen
stacking chess pieces the white King on
the white throne reflecting how despite
Parlin cutting them out of the will
ransom thinks the outsmarted the old man
and now he is going to be king of this
castle
it's also why when Marta is revealed as
the sole beneficiary paying some smiles
and lasts while everyone else is
freaking out this is all according to
his plan outside ransom beckons sue
Marta to help her and out of there
making these same gesture that Richard
made to her the night before just how
that was a manipulation ransom is
manipulating her as well in the diner
Marta tells ransom the truth
ransom is realizing that his initial
plan failed Marta was supposed to give
Harlan 100 milligrams of morphine that
was marked as a normal medication
instead Marta gave Harlan 100 milligrams
of the stuff marked as morphine the
correct medication and freaked out when
she saw the label which led to ransoms
plan backfiring and Harlan committing
suicide not having overdosed which would
allow Marta to get him to be the sole
beneficiary if you're listening to the
music here it's sundown by Gordon
Lightfoot the chorus is sundown ya
better take care if I find you creepin
round my back stairs it's a nod to how
both of these characters crept up in the
back entrance after sundown also
Lightfoot did write the song about Kathy
Smith who
we administered a fatal dosage of heroin
to John Belushi and ended up going to
prison for that overdose as Marta
worries will happen to her
Marta gets warned by the media and
demands by the family to renounce the
inheritance and receives this blackmail
letter when she takes it to ransom you
could see issues of The New Yorker on
his table Blanc had a recent profile in
The New Yorker which is how ransom knew
to hire him Marta and ransom believe the
same the burnt medical examiner's office
leading to this chasin in the alley
Marta drives past aggravating a symbol
the same symbol used on the clue to mark
the tunnel in Bryan Johnson's brick
Marta finds Fran odine but of course she
is saying you did this
identifying ransom by the name the
household staff uses for him Blanc and
Marta return to the house and find the
stash tox reports Blanc reads it chews
everyone out and rushes to the library a
doughnut hole in a doughnut hole but we
must look a little closer and when we do
we see the doughnut hole has a hole in
its center throughout the film we have
been teased shot of this insane iron
throne style night display but its
center has always been framed to the
side of the characters but finally here
Blanc sits framed with his head in the
direct center in the doughnut hole
within the doughnut hole
followed by Marta shifting over to the
doughnut hole because her unique
goodness is the hole within a hole under
Blanc's nose this whole time it also
makes her the target for the
backstabbing family surrounding her
notice how when blanc demonstrates the
label switching mix-up harder rubs her
eyes showing how she would not be seen
blanc in this moment changed the labels
for the demo and it proves that she
knows the correct medication by just
picking it up Branson's plot is revealed
when Etta telling Marta dramatically
follows her telling ransom earlier brand
witnessed him covering his tracks
blackmailed him with the tox report from
her cousin ransom burned the medical
examiner's office and killed Fran in
order to frame Marta and mortal eyes the
same Fran was alive and ready to confirm
the truth but notice she does not say
another word until after ransom
confesses to trying to kill Fran and
then yep she lied Fran is actually dead
making ransom a murderer
ransom responds by trying to stab Marta
but if they retractable knife Holly back
that second amazing detail about
Harlan's line earlier about ransom to a
different stage prop and a real knife
the film's epilogue brings the baseball
to home plate kept your eye on it the
baseball tracks the mystery subplot of
Richard's affair after finding Harlan's
letter to Linda apparently blank Richard
victoriously throws his baseball outside
shortly after Blanc picks up the
baseball and later exchanges it with a
dog to fetch for the trellis piece later
Linda retrieves the baseball from the
dog and now she returns it back to
Harlan's office and here she finds a
blank letter Richard opened and
recognizes one of her dad's old games
that she's been talking about allmovie
we had our own secret way of
communicating you had to find that with
dad he had to find a game to play with
him I was just thinking about dads games
and Linda plays this game using heat to
reveal the hidden message so really had
Richard not broken into the desk open
the letter and thrown the baseball
outside Linda probably would have never
found this letter Marta looks up at
Harlan's painting look closely it has
changed ever so slightly from when we
saw it in previous close-ups - now give
Harlan an approving smile
goosed mazing and the final shot of
families scowling up at Marta you can
see how Richard now has a black eye
probably from Linda hitman Florida sips
from Harlan's my house my rules mug as
the victorious owner of the house she
earned by living life not by playing the
game of the treacherous thrombi clan but
by her own rules knives out success is a
huge accomplishment by Rian Johnson
especially considering the film was not
a franchise or based on any source
material or a historical event audiences
just loved an original intricate
whodunit and the sequel will apparently
follow Benoit Blanc as the Holmes Perot
detective onto an entirely new mystery
which to me is the perfect way to go I'm
super excited comment down below with
your favorite detail from knives out and
what off-topic movie you'd like to see
new rock stars analyze next follow me
Eddie gave us followed new rockstars of
social media and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thank
you for watching and now onto my
they're thinking the good stuff
[Music]